الحروب والنزاعات المشتعله في افريقيا
خلفت كثيرا من الضحايا
فاطمه حسن لخشيتها من ان تقع ضحيه غليان
الصدور بين قبيلتها المتنازعه مع قبيله
اخرى مجاوره لها لجات مع عائلتها الى مخيم
اللاجئين فيجاد
لا نقدر على العوده اثناء الاشتباكات
شاهدنا كثيرا من الجثث منهم من قتل امام
اعيننا لا نستطيع العوده من بين نحو 100
الف لادن في تشات لجا نحو عشره الاف الى
هذا المخيم
عشرات المخيمات المشابهه يسكنها لاجئون من
افريقيا الوسطى ومن دارفور بالسودان ومن
نيجيريا
فالنزاعات المستمره في منطقه الساحل دفعت
ملايين الاشخاص الى اللجوء
وجراء الحروب في الكونغو الديمقراطيه وفي
شرق افريقيا بشكل عام فان اعداد النازحين
واللاجئين تحسب بالملايين
منظمات غير حكوميه شرعت في تنفيذ مشاريعه
تتيح للاجئين العمل في الزراعه في الاراضي
الممنوحه
المجاوره للمخيم سيء جردي
اذا كان لدينا اليوم نازحون او لاجئون
فالسبب يعود الى مشكله معروفه لا يمكن
تحقيق التنميه دون سلام او تعارف ولكي
تتقدم افريقيا يجب علينا احلال السلام
توفر المخيمات مسكنا وماوى مؤقتا لكن فرص
الحياه وتطوير الذات وبناء المستقبل لا
تكاد تذكر يمكن القول ان اللاجئين يكتفون
بحلم احلال السلام في ربع اوطانهم
والعوده الى ديارهم
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره من مخيم كلمباري
كندل غربي شات